durant trois ans monique néron et émilie
perreault ont suivi des victimes
d'agressions sexuelles et des membres de
l'appareil judiciaire pour comprendre
les failles du système
à l'intérieur même si c'est mon père
mais encore beaucoup de choses qui
viennent nuire aux victimes
les contre interrogatoires par exemple
sont des bébés des moments très très
difficiles
est ce qu'on constate également c'est le
fameux entonnoir où on va autoriser très
peu de plaintes qui vont se rendre
devant juge versus qui autorisera la
police et déjà la police
ce n'est que cinq pour cent à l'élagage
qu'ils ont peur elle expose également de
manière éloquente la froideur d'un
système qui aux violences sexuelles
subis par les victimes ajoute la
violence judiciaire juste magique peut
broyer les gens ont un problème de
société il faut accompagner ces gens là
je pense qu'on peut le faire mieux et
est ce que la parfaite victime raconte
c'est justement qu'on attend de ces
fusées de ces personnes-là hommes ou
femmes qui soient parfaites mais
personne n'est parfait
le film a été produit par denise robert
une habitude et documentaire choc elle
qui était également derrière les films
les voleurs d'enfance et dérapages de
paul arcand
c'est un film qui raconte des histoires
et puis elles nous touchent elles nous
font pleurer et c'est comme au cinéma
c'est des vrais histoire cette seule
différence d'un film de fiction c'est
des vrais histoire avait fait acquitter
beaucoup de clients n'aggraveront
sexuelle
je n'ai perdu aucune cause d'agressions
sexuelles c'est vraiment de prendre
conscience que c'est un problème qui
nous concerne tous qu au delà des
statistiques parce que les chiffres on
les connaît on les entendu depuis trois
ans mais le cd visage des voix c'est des
histoires donc je pense que le pouvoir
de l'empathie c'est celui du cinéma
ça envoie un drôle de visage pour une
personne qui est victime le film
souligne que la victime parfaite
n'existe pas le système judiciaire
parfait non plus mais il ya place à
l'amélioration
ce documentaire est une prise de parole
de plus un film nécessaire pour qu'un
jour la peur et la honte change de camp
est-ce que j'en conclu qu'on a à faire
problème ici n'est bien lexandre
chartier radio canada montréal